vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir un triste
anniversaire ce soir cela fait un an que
le journaliste français olivier dubois
et détenus au mali s'il est l'unique
otages français détenus dans le monde il
y as et la somalie plusieurs autres
personnes détenues par des groupes
jihadistes nous irons à bamako dès le
début de ce journal
une victoire de david contre goliath en
afrique du sud la petite communauté koei
qui a réussi à suspendre les travaux du
géant américain amazon un projet qui
risque est de détruire son site sacré
reportage à suivre de nos correspondants
et c'est le retour de l'art contemporain
africain à paris avec la foire à 54
jusqu'à ce dimanche la foire se déroule
pour la deuxième édition l'occasion et
de découvrir des artistes du continent
et de la diaspora
olivier dubois est un journaliste
indépendant de 47 ans qui est détenu
depuis un an par une organisation
terroriste au mali c'est l'unique otages
français détenus dans le monde le
président emmanuel macron à d'ailleurs
assuré la pleine mobilisation de l'état
pour mettre je cite un terme à
l'insupportable séquestration du
journaliste pour en parler on retrouve
son ami et ancien collègue porte parole
du comité de soutien au mali célia
d'almeida syli à d'almeida merci de nous
retrouver sur france 24
dites nous
dit nous de quelles informations déjà
vous disposez sur la détention d'olivier
dubois
oh merci beaucoup pour cette opportunité
je crois que mon en savons pas plus que
depuis l'an dernier depuis mai 2021
puisque c'est à cette date là le 5 mai
que nous avons eu confirmation de
l'enlèvement de
olivier on sait qu'il est de tenues par
l'europe de soutien à l'islam et aux
musulmans le gym on sait qu'il a été
enlevé au canada où il était parti en
reportage on sait qu'il est qu il a
donné deux preuves de vie donc la
première en mai et la deuxième récemment
le 13 mars avec cette vidéo qui nous est
parvenu dans laquelle on voit qu'il est
qu'il est en bonne santé qu'ils
s'expriment bien qu'il qu'il reçoit les
messages que nous lui envoyons et qu'il
continue de demander qu'on travaille à
ce qu'il à ce qu'il soit libéré donc en
gros en tout cas au niveau du comité
nous n'avons pas de nouvelles
informations officielles sur la
situation d'olivier vous avez entendu
les propos du président français
emmanuel macro qui assure et la
mobilisation de l'état français
qu'attendez-vous des autorités
françaises et maliennes pour la
libération d'olivier dubois
olivier l'a un peu dire dans la vidéo du
13 mars dernier
le son soit sa situation
peut ne pas paraître prioritaire à nos
autorités et pourtant et pourtant c'est
un père c'est un c'est un homme c'est un
journaliste c'est un c'est une
personnalité engagée autant pour la
france que pour le mali un pays qu'il
qu'il porte dans son coeur qu'il chérit
et et pour lequel il veut faire
connaître la situation est donc moi
j'espère et je pense que tous les amis
du comité ne me démentiront pas que la
situation d'olivier reste une priorité
pour nos autorités qu'elles soient
françaises ou malienne et que tout ce
qu'il est possible de faire soit fait
bien entendu en ayant à l'esprit la
question évidemment de sa sécurité est
alors malheureusement et olivier dubois
n'est pas l'unique otages détenus au
mali elles sont nombreuses à celles qui
sont encore détenus par les djihadistes
et pas uniquement des journalistes oui
absolument madame juan olivier et le
le journaliste le sol français
aujourd'hui officiellement retenu sur le
sol malien il y a malheureusement des
dizaines voire des centaines de
personnes qui sont encore tenues par
différents groupes
dans le nord dans le centre ce sont des
leaders communautaires ce sont des
administrateurs ville ce sont des
militaires beaucoup beaucoup de
militaires et il y à olivier et deux
autres journalistes sont là deux
confrères maliens amadou ni à l'éboulis
et moussa ban a dit causes qui sont
retenus aussi dans le centre un peu plus
longtemps qu olivier est donc vraiment
on espère que que leur situation va
vraiment rester au devant de l'actualité
quelques elle qu'elle va être une
priorité
quelque chose sur laquelle vont rester
concentré nos autorités pour travailler
à leur libération parce que ce sont des
pères de famille des mères de famille ce
sont des d'aider des parents des amis
des collègues qui manque aux leurs et et
dont la contribution à nos états ne peut
être démentis et donc on espère que tout
sera fait vraiment tout sera fait pour
qu'ils puissent revenir bientôt a alors
merci beaucoup célia d'almeida pour
votre message et on espère évidemment
que olivier dubois sera bientôt bientôt
libérés ainsi que tous les autres otages
merci beaucoup célia d'almeida la
communauté d'afrique de l'est s'agrandit
aujourd'hui la république démocratique
du congo rejoint le kenya la tanzanie le
burundi le rwanda l'ouganda et le soudan
du sud pour dans cette organisation
régionale pour l'occasion félix
tshisekedi le président congolais s'est
rendu à nairobi où il a signé le traité
qui intègre officiellement son pays en
présence du président kenyan mais aussi
de yoweri musevini et de paul kagamé
anaérobie notre correspondant bastien
rogne
la république démocratique du congo est
le septième et à rejoindre la communauté
d'afrique de l'est qu'est ce que cela va
lui apporter bien principalement des
avantages commerciaux dans un premier
temps faut savoir que cela signifie la
levée des barrières douanières notamment
donc si la rdc souhaite importer ou
exporter en grand nombre de biens et
bien elle n'aura plus besoin de payer de
taxes pour un très grand nombre deux
produits cela lui garantit aussi un
accès privilégié au port de mombasa et
de dar es salaam qui sont les principaux
ports d'afrique de l'est ensuite cela
apporte des avantages au niveau du
mouvement des personnes puisque les
citoyens congolais n'auront plus besoin
de visa pour se rendre dans les autres
pays d'afrique de l'est ils pourront
donc accéder au kenya l'ouganda ou
encore au burundi sans titre de séjour
pourront s'y installer et y travailler
ensuite il ya aussi une composante
politique les états qui composent la
communauté d'afrique de l'est et bien
sont censés se tourner dans un futur
proche vers une sorte de fédéralisme où
il y aurait un grand pays qui prendrait
des décisions communes et qui pèserait
plus sur la scène internationale mais
pour l'heure est bien les discussions
n'avancent pas beaucoup après près de
deux décennies de débats entre les pays
de la région
quand ces mesures entreront tél en
fonctionnement difficile à dire
probablement au cours des prochains mois
puisqu'il faut encore que le parlement
congolais bien les ratifie tout et il
faut aussi que les administrations de
tous les pays voisins de la rdc bien
applique toutes ces règles et cela
prendra un petit peu de temps avant que
tout soit mis en place
question le terrain une explosion
d'origine indéterminée a fait ce jeudi
soir six morts et trois blessés dans
l'est du pays c'est un bar d'un camp
militaire de goma qui a été visé le chef
lieu du nord kivu est une province de la
rdc en proie à des violences depuis 25
ans par de nombreux groupes sable
et ce vendredi une attaque dans le nord
du burkina faso a fait 16 morts dont 12
soldats et quatre supplétifs de l'armée
l'attaqué est attribuée des djihadistes
présumés il savait depuis 2015 le pays
est en froid des violences qui ont fait
plus de 2000 morts et près de 2 millions
de déplacés
on passe à cette histoire qui rappelle
celle de david contre goliath en afrique
du sud la petite communauté cole a
réussi à faire plier amazon elle a
obtenu la suspension des travaux de près
de 300 millions d'euros du siège du
géant américain la construction risquer
de détruire son site sacré les
industriels impliqués dans le projet ont
toutefois fait appel de la décision
reportage au cap de nos correspondants
caroline dumas stéphane
les leaders traditionnels qu ils font
régulièrement des cérémonies de
purification pour protéger leurs sites
sacrés t harry jenkins représentent
certaines tribus coy des populations qui
étaient déjà en afrique du sud avant que
les hollandais ne s'y installe au xviie
siècle
là où nous sommes en ce moment ce sont
les premières terres qui ont été volés
dans ce pays la compagnie néerlandaise
des indes orientales qui était l'une des
plus grosses à l'époque à donner à ses
employés des fermes jusqu'au là où nous
sommes sur les berges de ces rivières
nous nous sommes battus contre les
forces coloniales c'est un endroit qui a
une signification extraordinaire autant
sur le plan historique de spiritueux
voilà ce que tarik et ses amis essaient
d'arrêter la construction d'un complexe
de près de 300 millions d'euros qui
abritera le siège africain du géant
amazon la communauté coy et divisé
tout le monde ne soutient pas l'arrêt de
ce projet qui créera des emplois
ce chef par exemple préfèrent que la
construction continue car on lui a
promis un centre culturel pour une
séance
on en avait assez des blocages
administratifs marque personne ne nous
écoute
alors quand on s'est allié aux
industriels on a réussi à obtenir ce que
personne ne nous a donnés il pas même le
gouvernement
on nous promet un centre culturel ultra
moderne sur notre héritage
au milieu de ce complexe commercial
la justice sud africaine a suspendu la
construction les industriels ont fait
appel le juge demande à ce que toutes
les parties se mettent d'accord
1,54 est de retour à paris pour sa
deuxième édition la foire d'art
contemporain africain s'installe à
nouveau chez christie's cinquante
artistes sont à l'affiché cette année
venant du continent et de la diaspora
comme la tunisienne aïcha ce no 6 qui
fait dans sa pratique artistique plutôt
de l'archéologie artistique comme dans
cette oeuvre magnifique présenté au mot
cossette était de montpellier la
sépulture au noyer aïcha snow ci sera
aussi à suivre au palais tokyo dès la
semaine prochaine à paris et un autre
artiste à suivre toujours dans cette
fois à 54 c'est mathieu hangover peintre
nigérian qui cherche à montrer une
afrique différents libre et moderne
écoutez le au micro de célia karacena et
myriam bendjillali
en tant qu'artiste je trouve que les
africains ont été mal représentée par le
passé
j'essaie d'utiliser mon travail pour
montrer ce que l'afrique est vraiment
avec cette toile je veux montrer qu'on
n'est pas limitée dans nos choix je veux
donner de la confiance aux gens vous
êtes africains vous pouvez faire ce que
vous voulez de votre vie dans le passé
il y avait des combats entre hommes
africains juste pour le divertissement
mais aujourd'hui on ne veut plus être du
divertissement pour le monde les autres
les africains font des choses très forte
très positive
s est ainsi que nous refermons ce
journal l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis de tunis à goma un
passant par mike robby rester avec nous
car l'actualité continue sur france 4
[Musique]